you can see our next guest at the la
comedy club inside the strat and you can
see his new special from las vegas butch
bradley
on all digital platforms starting today
here he is
it's butch bradley what's going on butch
great to be here
hey how i am of your air
you're fan of your hair look
i'm just scaring your hair the whole
time like uh that is a work
art it takes it takes a while and it
takes a lot of actually it takes a lot
of uh it takes a lot of product i
actually carry around product to get it
to stick up like this
let's talk about you let's talk about
you because you were just named
best comedian 2020 by best of las vegas
how do you feel to get that honor
you know it's a big it's a big week
vegas is where you know the giants come
to play
it's an incredible city filled with
mind-blowing
so the huge pool have happened
so when your new special that's out
today all digital platforms when did you
film the special did you film it during
the pandemic you know what
vegas gave me the special i took that
residency at the la comedy club
and then one magical evening after being
look i was in la for 12 years then i'm
at the la comedy club
on a dead tuesday night and sean
director sean mcnamara shows up from
soul surfer
my buddy eric all day and uh a couple of
other guys
and basically uh just you know tells me
he wants to do uh
uh you know a special with me so uh
um you know i'm not sure just what
happened there but i'll keep going
so it was a magical moment in the la
comedy club hollywood came to vegas
and just changed my whole uh career
we filmed it in june and then uh this is
more comedy than ever
you gotta get your camera locked in
there my camera has covered it's like
but no it's an incredible thing i got a
deal on the special out of the club
and um everyone came together so i'm
getting a lot of buzz in the heat on it
and it's a cool thing i'm excited
let's talk about your background cause
you have freddie mercury behind you is
queen your favorite band
you know it is one of my favorite bands
we have a bunch of artists in here
and uh you know i grew up in atlantic
city in a casino town around music
and comedians so uh this is just a cool
time you know and uh
sean mcnamara has just been a you know a
changing element my life he
threw me in the ronald reagan movie that
comes out september called reagan with
dennis quaid
and i think growing up like a lot of
people here in the casino biz
we absorb all that art and uh just
natural for me to be on stage and
especially
very cool to be in vegas on stage let's
talk about this you're in the new reagan
movie what what what's your role what
are you playing
i play uh the continentals so
ronald reagan's career was kind of on
dying and he went to the frontier casino
bringing it back to vegas it's history
the frontier casino hired him he came
out
and he was surrounded with four guys
called the continentals
and he hated that time of his life but
um you know uh for me that moment i get
to play the continental i had three full
seeds with dennis quaid
uh it was an unbelievable scene to do
and uh just
incredible hollywood experience it's
gorgeous and that whole section is based
on vegas
so vegas just keeps helping my life
vegas
it's magic well you're out you're giving
back to las vegas which is really cool
you're doing something for first
responders after first responders
watching
tell them what you're doing for them
well we're gonna do
uh two full shows for the first
responders
uh at the la comedy club but i wanna add
anybody that's a first responder
police fire ambulance drivers you know
doctors
i i've always you know loved what you do
i've done a ton of shows for the
military
and afghanistan iraq it's in my heart i
do the
big shows here in vegas the rock of
honor shows for the police unity tour
and now we're going to make sure you
guys have your own shows at the la
comedy club
in march 21st and 28th i believe in the
dates
but honestly if you find me on instagram
and you guys need a show
i'll come wherever you are you sneak me
into the hospital wing
and i'll i'll do a little dance right
there for you i love it we appreciate it
butch and i'll send you some product to
get the hair going up just like mine
should be all set gonna help
i don't think it's gonna help you got it
dialed in remember butch is having free
stand-up shows for first responders
at the la comedy club inside the strat
march 21st and march 28th at 4pm
thanks butch mercedes over to you mommy
guys